[Music]
let me throw out another
mnemonic of sorts but it's it's a very
short
phrase
that i'd love to hear you speak to in
any way that makes sense mood follows
action
i love that one um that was something
that my
first sponsor said to me very early on
in sobriety i think i was complaining to
him about some
commitment i had made to sweep the
floors or make coffee or
something along those lines or or
something that had happened to me that
day that i was annoyed with and i
couldn't see my way through
and
and he just said you know he said mood
follows action and what he meant by that
is
you can't
you can't
think your way
into
into the mood that you seek or the state
of mind that you aspire to inhabit
action is the only thing that can
trigger that change state
and i literally think about this every
single day and it was validated recently
in a podcast that i did with andrew
huberman who i know has been on your
show
where he studied the neurochemistry of
this and realized that
behavior has to come first and thoughts
perceptions emotions follow from that
and when you think about that in the
context of our daily lives like let's
just use running for example like if you
wake up in the morning and you're
supposed to do
a run because you're training for some
race and you don't feel like doing it we
all
resort to that state where we think well
i don't want to do it right now i'll
just wait until i feel like doing it and
then i'll do it then and when we
when we engage
that way we end up never doing it right
like if you're waiting until you feel
like doing something chances are you're
probably never going to get to it but to
take the action despite how you feel
about it is the thing that catalyzes the
state change and you know in my case or
anybody who's a runner
they'll tell you when they finish the
run they're always glad that they did it
they don't generally regret it and then
they feel better and i think that that
example is applicable to you know all
areas of life
you